Maureen is with us in New York a marine
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show yes Dave
so long to be talking to you you too
what's up okay so I have a side hustle
and it earns me about twenty to twenty
four thousand dollars a year and I
really want to get rid of it it it pulls
my focus from my main job I run around
at least two days sometimes three days a
week for it but every time I tell my
husband that I want to let it go he's
like well you always manage to get it
done so I was like you know I'm gonna
call Dave and see what he thinks
based on our current situation so we're
baby steps - we're doing Dave ish
because I've had to play a little bit of
mental warfare on my husband and had to
play your podcast in my car enough to
make him think that it was his idea to
do this and so we have one car loan left
up it for $20,000 and we have $60,000 in
the bank
I just can't get him to part with it to
pay off the truck and we earn about
$300,000 a year
do I just end up children say hey I'm
quitting this side hustle you're in
$300,000 a year and you guys are moaning
about a $24,000 decision I know all you
have enough money in the bank to pay off
your car I know and to fund a fund
emergency and I could be in for five and
six and you know at sunset I know this
is - yeah I know
terrible oh just wonderful problems to
have you know so I guess like a lot of
folk when you call here you already knew
the answer right yeah I'm just I was
looking for your support yeah well you
have my support I'm pretty consistent
yeah pay off your stupid truck put your
mergency phone aside quit your little
dinky but job you make 300k you're gonna
be okay but you're only gonna be okay if
the two of you can learn to get on the
same page and both of you quit being sad
blame obstinate this is crazy I don't
know how I mean you're really the
biggest impediment to your future wealth
building is
fact that you two can't make a simple
decision like this together I mean my
goodness you are really struggling with
unity in there so that's a big deal all
the data points tell us that couples
have been wealth almost always work
together and you all aren't you're
having to do what was it warfare or
something would you call it I mean you
know that's you know yeah yeah quit your
job pay off your bills pay off your
bills quit your job get on the same page
yeah yeah yeah my support